my books wouldn't be as good if I if I
haven't gone through that trauma welcome
Richard Osmond ladies and gentlemen
best-selling novelist television
producer presented you know if you have
a trauma of any type and and you are
looked after and you're guided through
it you can come out the other side if
however you're sort of left alone in
your trauma your own Solutions never
work
I never sat and thought oh I've got a
problem with my life but I would have
addictive behaviors around food when did
you realize that it was their strange
Behavior I mean it's an addiction
there's no other way of putting it it's
like having a bottle of vodka then
having another bottle of vodka then
having another bottle of vodka if you
see somebody is different they do not
need to be told I've had that with my
height you know and I know you're just
thinking yeah but it's just me you think
yeah but it's just you and five other
people every single day I didn't live
the life I should have done for many
years I wish I'd been more myself in
those years and I would have taken much
less success and much more happiness
what what is happiness gosh that's a
good question well here's the way I
always think about it
that makes a lot of sense you think
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I could have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
the show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
[Music]
Richard Stephen
what do I need to know about you and
your earliest years to understand the
man you went on to be and all the things
you went on to do uh it's a good
question well if you mean professionally
the man I I went on to be
um I grew up loving popular culture
loving mainstream culture loving
mainstream television
um so you know that's always been in my
soul I came from a big working class
family and now find myself in a very
middle class world so I I sort of have a
sense of what different people
um from different places in Britain like
to watch or like to read uh so that
really and you know I grew up I've I've
visually very visually impaired so I
don't see the world particularly
brilliantly but I'm always listening to
the world I'm always interested in what
people are saying and you know getting
that sort of thing so I think that
combination of things means I've I've
had a career of sort of working out what
people might quite like and then finding
the right people to help me make those
things your your earliest years kind of
reminded me of mine in many ways because
I I almost view my earliest years as two
chapters there was for me there was the
first chapter which was really Pleasant
I remember it being a very happy home
and then there was a second chapter
which I could describe basically as
dysfunctional yes and a bit of a bit of
a nightmare yeah there's the the
similarities so I was I was I was nine
my father left when I was nine and this
being the 1970s we didn't really see him
again it wasn't sort of it wasn't touchy
feely oh everyone still loves each other
it was you know off off he went and so
yeah I was probably the same but quite
happy-go-lucky up to that age and then
afterwards you sort of have to you know
build a mask for yourself a little bit
and you know pretend you're okay and
pretend you're not in pain uh weirdly
that ability to sort of create your own
narrative was helpful in my related to
create career you know I'd rather not
have had it but that ability to sort of
pretend that everything's okay and to
write a different story
um which is which is uh very much what I
did but um
yeah I think that anyone who's had that
sort of Disconnect uh it affects them
one way or another and it was very you
know an unhappy time and it's litter
lots of unhappiness uh since then but it
doesn't make me unhappy anymore for sure
I've absolutely come to terms with it
come to peace with it
um and you know I always say trauma is
not the problem it's an inability to
deal with trauma is the problem you know
if you have a trauma of any type and and
you are looked after and you're guided
through it you can probably come out the
other side if however you're sort of
left alone in your trauma and you come
up with your own Solutions your own
Solutions never work and so I definitely
had that but some
I try and use and you know I'm very
connected still to the nine-year-old
weirdly because I've had that sort of
interregnum where I was a slightly
different person so I'm always able to
um I'm always able to find that
nine-year-old and that nine-year-old was
very interested in new things and what's
on telly and you know uh who's playing
football this afternoon and you know
what's in the pop charts and you know
that's the stuff that I loved when I was
nine and it's the stuff that I still
love now I'm always always what's next
what's next what's next you talk he
talked I think it was a Sunday Times
interview you did where you said at that
age you had to manufacture yourself a
little bit and I found that really
interesting because I've heard this a
few times from a few different people
I've sat here with that have undergone
uh sort of a tectonic shift in their
early years yeah what do you mean by
manufacture yourself a little bit well I
think when you get into your teenage
years you are working out who you are
and you know we could we we all of us
change and we change in you know in
reaction to the world around us and the
new things that we experience and new
friends and new schools you know we
become different people but I think if
at the heart of it there is a lie so my
lie would be everything is okay I don't
need my dad to be around it's okay that
I hear my mum crying at night you know
if that's my lie then everything I build
is built on a fault line you know so
everything is built on that fault line
so however big I build the you know my
personality there's going to come a
point and it happened to me probably
late 20s when there's an earthquake
because that fault line gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger so it's
just but you we all build our
personalities and if you build them on
truth if you build them on firm
foundations if you build them on good
faith then you know you have a chance if
you build them on fault lines then it
always comes out
that makes a lot of sense you think yeah
because that's that's completely
consistent with when I've sat here with
people who've spent Decades of their
life or Decades of their career even
um building themselves up on a lies but
or as you've referred to it as a wearing
a mask
um the the earthquake always comes well
here's the way I always think about it
listen people tell you there's no such
thing as truth and of course that that's
true I get it there's no such thing as
actual reality but I think our
personalities we sort of have a true
north right which if nothing goes wrong
or if we respond to trauma well we carry
on our life and that true north goes up
through us and we sort of dance around
it and we can sort of wander in and out
the fields around this sort of true
north if you deviate from True North
especially very young then suddenly True
North is here and you're heading off in
this direction right and for quite a
while you're not very far from your true
north but if you're like 15 20 years in
you're so far away from what you should
be right now you don't know that you're
telling a lie okay that's the absolute
key you don't know that you're lying to
yourself right so what you're seeing is
the reality of the world
seems alien to you and you can't work
out why you think why don't why don't I
fit in what why am I not sort of doing
the right things and it's because you're
so far away from where you need to be
and lots of people will fill that Gap
with um addictions and drugs and booze
and weird behaviors but eventually I
think most people work out the reason
the world doesn't seem right is I'm not
right you know and some people
narcissists will try and drag the world
to them
Trump he tries to drag the world to him
all the time okay because of his
childhood and which we get right but
most people at some point just go no I
need I've got to make that leap I've got
to LEAP back to where I was which is a
long journey but but a worthwhile one
but I think it's just we just keep going
just slightly off course slightly off
course and the longer that goes on for
the further we are from where we should
be if you were to
um have stayed on your true north um
throughout that whole period what would
you have done instead oh well it's a
very good question uh I sort of think
that I would have done roughly the same
thing I think I would have ended up in
in TV or journalism or writing one way
or another I think that
and especially think this with the books
I think that it has given me an empathy
for
people and for pain until you know I see
pain in other people all the time and I
see Denial in other people all the time
and I think those things go through the
books so I think my books wouldn't be as
good if I if I haven't gone through that
trauma uh you know and again I trade the
two off in a heartbeat so I think I
would have done the same thing but I
don't think it would have had the same
Soul as the truth and therefore I don't
think it would have had quite the same
impact or success you say you trade the
two off in a heartbeat yeah What
happiness for because I mean listen you
you've been enormously successful right
but the question is why
okay what are you after right are you
after money okay you're off the money
but why what's it what is it that money
is doing for you it can buy you certain
things okay why do you want those things
what are they doing for you and the
answer is always one thing which is
happiness contentment right just comfort
in and of yourself that's all you want
is to wake up in the morning and be
comfortable with who you are to have
enough and to be comfortable with who
you are uh and I think that you know
that's the thin happiness is the only
thing we seek and if I'd grown up
happier I think I would have found
happiness easier to find and you know my
happiness has been hard won and I'm
happy that you know now it's great
because I'm 51 and I'm I'm in this
lovely place but then you know there's
sort of 10 15 years where you think oh
you know what I wish I'd I wish I'd been
more myself in those years uh and I
would have taken much less success and
much more happiness it's funny I asked
that question because I remember mogada
sitting here and talking to me about the
Eraser test they did on people where
they asked people if you could remove
the most traumatic events of your life
would you do it and he says that 95 of
people says they would say they wouldn't
yeah I think it's interesting that
because I I don't think people I I don't
think it's a real question because what
you're really saying to people is would
you erase who you are yeah and would you
erase and you know of course you
wouldn't of course you would not erase
who you are because it's very dear to
you however
if you were able to live that other
reality and live this reality and see
which one of these do you prefer I think
you'd say the one without the trauma is
my opinion none of us would ever say yes
I want to erase who I was okay I mean
it's crazy but actually the truth is if
we had the two side by side like a you
know a Costa and a Starbucks and say
which would you prefer we would pick the
uh we'd pick the the uh which is the
best one I don't know either I think I
don't know exactly what I think I don't
know what I don't know what's the cost
of All-Star vaccine they're both fine
companies I imagine there's a lot of
people listening to this now that have
had a traumatic event happen to them or
of course are going to have traumatic
events in their future
what I'm really interested in is knowing
the impact that your decision to no
longer see your dad and however else you
behaved at that time had on you later
how in hindsight do you think it would
have been better to act
better for me to act yeah I don't think
it's a question for me because I'm 10 10
11 years old right and I'm not I'm I'm
I'm not the sort of significant actor in
that situation you know you you're not
able to rationalize the world correctly
you know it's for the people around you
and there's no disrespect by the way to
the people around me because you have
very very different times and my mum had
just been through the most extraordinary
trauma I mean much more than I had been
through and so she was not in a position
to act in my best interest there and my
dad wasn't in a better position to to
work in my interest and nobody was no
one knew you know it was a lot to talk
about mental health now and isn't it you
know but no one talked about that stuff
but then I mean they really really
didn't talk about that stuff back then
you know it just didn't exist you know
you it was the sort of Hangover from the
kind of post-war years where you just
didn't complain you know and that that's
still the mindset we had so listen if if
it happened uh more recently yeah it
would have been much simpler and listen
I'd have found a different trauma you
know is personality type seek out trauma
is the truth uh and I would have found a
different trauma
um to explain away my differences but I
think that um yeah I think that had it
happen 30 years later conversations
would have been had people would have
sat in rooms that would have worked out
what the best to do was but it's the
world was such a different place in sort
of 1979 it sort of feels very very
recent to me uh but you know the world
the world was an entirely different
place and we didn't even have to have
those conversations in 1992 when I was
born yeah I think that's right they
started showing up about 10 years ago I
think the conversations around mental
health and mental well-being before then
even the prospect of being mentally ill
had this like horrible stigma associated
with like stray jackets and asylums not
no we didn't think of the fact that we
all have mental health I think I think
that's exactly right and listen there's
an awful lot wrong with our this new
social media age but one of the good
things is if you are different then you
are supported and you have friendships
around you unless you're also attacked
that's the problem with social media age
because you know suddenly you're seeing
as a group but you are supported and you
can find like-minded people you can find
people in the same position no one at my
school was from divorced parents you
know it just didn't you know when I went
to comprehensive school was a few more
but not really and now of course you
know you can be on you know you can be
online and you can meet a thousand
people in your situation in one evening
you know and that I think it would would
be rather helpful you've talked about
how you've come to peace with that
resentment that you had with your father
how oh easily because he's a human being
and I got it and I got to the age that
he was when he left saw the situation
that he had found himself in and I
thought yeah I get it I see why he would
do that you know I did the same you know
I left the mother of my children
um hopefully in a very different way but
um you know I absolutely get her he
found himself in a situation he couldn't
get out of
um so ran away and you know I met him in
later life and he's an alright guy he
knows a perfectly decent man but he
didn't have the language and he didn't
have the brain space for for that sort
of conflict we just didn't have it he
just was in a situation he didn't want
to be in and ran away which is which is
very common and again people you know do
it less now because you know you can
talk to people and Men didn't talk to
other men then you know he found himself
at a place in life where he just thought
I'm not who I need to be you know I'm
unhappy and so he found an excuse and
left and so I've always you know I have
no resentment towards him anymore I get
it I sort of wish that I loved him and I
wish that there was that I felt that
love and I wish that I had that big sort
of family thing but gosh there's worse
problems in the world
um but but of course I understand why
you did it you know this is the age-old
story people have been doing it for
generations and they'll keep doing it
empathy was your yeah I think so and and
it's um an empathy for one's enemies I
don't we should call him an enemy but
you know what I mean for someone who's
an antagonist in your life rather than a
protagonist people talk a lot about
empathy and I think they don't have
empathy for their their opponents or for
people who disagree with them or for
people who've lived a different
experience and you think that's empathy
empathy is not just saying I feel sorry
for people or can we help people you
know that of course is empathy and it's
kindness but empathy is also why does
half the country disagree with me you
know why does half the country live
their life in a different way why do
they not care about what I care about
that's actual empathy and that's that
that's in shorter Supply I would say but
you're learning to forgive someone who's
caused you trauma uh and not just forget
but understand
the French say to understand all is to
forgive all which which I sort of I sort
of get
um you know if you're inside someone's
head you go okay I see it I see why you
did it so listen I'd rather he hadn't
done it but I understand entirely why he
did and and yeah that's that's I guess a
a very good example of empathy the sort
of empathy that you wish you didn't have
to have but um you know it's very useful
you needed more information on his
contacts to get that empathy or was it
because you use the word learning to
forgive yeah which I think is an app to
work because it's not easy to to do that
it's not just a decision week well it is
I guess to somehow but it's a very
difficult decision to make to to really
well I mean look in in my situation I
hadn't seen it for 20 years and that I
did see him
um maybe a bit maybe 18 years and so
yeah I'd had a long time to Build That
Wall around me I had a long I had you
know I'd had conversations with him in
my head a lot and you know the
conversations you have people who aren't
there become very powerful and you know
you'll constantly have that conversation
again this is what I would say this is
why I would say uh and then you meet up
and you start saying a couple of those
things and you're just there with a gun
AI who's just said I was just unhappy
and you know I love you and you know I
wish I hadn't had to do it you just go
it takes the sting out of all the
conversations you've had over the years
now for me he didn't have the
conversations with me that I needed you
know there was no it wasn't really
apologetic he didn't really understand
the first thing he said to me is I I bet
you wonder what I've been up to since I
left and I thought not really you know I
sort of think maybe what I've been up to
might be of interest to you and so he he
he just didn't he didn't have he didn't
have the vocabulary to to reform the
relationship it's the truth
um and I sort of felt he hadn't needed
it but I I said to him towards the end
of his life I did say
have you had a happy life there have you
had a happy life since you left and he
said yes I thought you know what that's
that's fine for me that'll do me listen
it's I'd rather he was happy but um yeah
it's uh
it's it's a it's a long journey to sort
of go
do you know what I get why you did it
and now the stuff that I built up around
it is now my responsibility and and it's
my thing to deal with not his
and in the interview I think with the
Sunday Times you said you you went to
his funeral and you found yourself very
you found yourself upset but not at what
one would think yeah I went down with my
brother funny enough who had even lesser
Doom with him than I did and my kids
were there and it was so unemotional
uh and you know I was very careful you
know I thought no come remember that
sometimes these things hit you and this
is your father and he's died uh and
I couldn't connect with him I cried
briefly at the end because I cried
because of what could have been because
of the relationship I've missed but I
wasn't crying for him uh and from the
next day almost it didn't hit me again
there was no kind of Aftershock uh and
that's sort of that that's really upset
me that there was not because I'm an
emotional very emotional person I'll cry
anything I'll cry at the repair shop uh
and I was sort of thinking this this is
not knocked me particularly uh and I
thought that was very sad because what a
waste of love you know what a waste of
things that could have been and my
brother was the same I could you know I
said to my kids did Uncle Matt cry and
they went no no
so you know it's it's the same thing and
you know people around him were crying
and you know the people who he loved and
who loved him so he'd built that life
you know without us but for me I just
thought oh that's there it is you know
my grandparents funerals I was crying
with my father's funeral it was just I
was glad I was there but there was there
was it just you can't lie and pretend
that it connects when it doesn't
you seem to be more significantly more
shaped by Brenda ah my mum yeah no I'm
definitely so I'm definitely shaped by
her I didn't have any other option than
to be shaped by her because uh it was
just me her and my brother in the house
yeah and I was very lucky to whatever my
trauma and listen we can overestimate
these things because I was brought up in
a very loving household and brought up
in a very smart household my mum uh it
became a primary school teacher uh after
my dad left and you know just very wise
and very protective and you know uh so I
I really in the sort of Lottery of
life's parents I I have to accept that
the one I had was an awful lot better
than the two that many people have
give me a flavor of her character and
personality in her
her Mana well she's let's say she's a
she's a primary school teacher so she's
used to um
you know if you ever went into a into a
class that my mom's teaching they'd be
silent if she wanted them to be silent
but she's very very softly spoken and
where she is now in her Retirement
Village which is the basis of the
Thursday Murder Club books she's
surrounded by people with very strong
opinions and very strong personalities
and my mum looks like she wouldn't say
boo to a goose she looks like she's very
unassuming uh but you know I know after
these big meetings when they're all
shouting each other my mum will be the
one to stand up and just say I wonder if
we should do this and give the solution
to the thing you know while everyone
else's egos are sort of blown themselves
out she sort of slips in and sort of
says I wonder if we do this and that's
not just by the way oh I'm kindly and
wise it's also she wants to get her own
way and she knows she knows that that's
the way to do it so yes she's she's very
bright very quiet very unassuming uh and
sort of is the opposite of of a tiger
mother you know these mothers that make
sure you're doing you know piano
practice and French lessons and you're
learning Mandarin and all this kind of
stuff she just she let me watch TV she
let my brother play his guitar and sort
of trusted that we'd find out our way in
life and that's I think
certainly for me and my brother often
the best way to bring up kids is to is
to let them find what they love and just
let them get on with it
that decision to just let you watch the
Telly um
pretty formative I guess well yeah and
and you know listen we can always look
back in hindsight and go she was a
genius she knew that that was going to
be my career but I think that she
realized when I was watching TV that I
wasn't doing it passively and which is
true when I was watching TV I was always
looking at the credits who does what on
a TV show what are the names of these
people and you know if there were jokes
on a sitcom thinking oh that's
interesting why did that make me laugh
at that that bit doesn't make me laugh
or formats you know how why do they
always end on a round and a quiz show
where you can catch up loads of points
what's that about so I was never
watching passively I was always I was
fascinated with I was always interested
with it uh and I think that she I sit
with my son and computer can actually
plays games all the time but then he's
talking to me about the industry and
he's talking to me about how they
monetize it and he's talking to me about
you know different forms of games and I
just think great you could keep playing
games then because that's the thing that
you love and as long as you're
interested in how it's put together then
you know that can become a career and I
don't think my mum thought that I ever
would have a career in teddics we didn't
know anybody like that but I think she
just sort of trusted did that something
was going in and that you know I was
never interested in school work I just
not it wasn't my thing at all I could
get by but it never sparked my interest
really but TV always did and the stuff I
was watching and Sport always did you
know I'd watch and watch and watch and
that's you know almost all my lessons
would take you know again with someone
who's very visually impaired I can sit
up very close to the Telly so you know
so many of my lessons are from TV not
not from the real world because the real
world I can't really see it you know
you can't really see it well
everything's in a fog I mean that's the
that's the point so I I never noticed
details if I want to see a bird in a
tree or a cricket ball going towards a
bat I can't that's not something I can
see never will do we can't drive or
anything like that it was on TV the
whole world
is out there I can go and you know I've
never been a big traveler or anything
like that I want to stay at home but I
can watch any country in the world on
television you know that's the thing
that I can see and
I'm interested the reason I don't want
to travel is I don't want to travel I
don't want to get on a plane I don't
want all of that but I want to learn
about places I want to see things and TV
you just it just shows you everything
and it showed me everything and it
introduced me to people and you know
even now I watch daytime TV I get so
much information about human beings from
watching those shows and seeing people's
reactions which I don't see in real life
you know because I'm up close to it I
get to see it all and TV's given me all
of that you know and uh
I think TV is so huge and such a huge
part of our culture we sort of I think
we forget it exists I think we forget
quite what a powerful thing it is we
talk about Cinema and music and all this
kind of stuff
and this is the age of Television you
know this is my generation I think
perhaps that your generation the next
one is going to be much less so but
television is the thing that's in the
corner of everybody's rooms you know and
it shows us so many things it teaches us
so many things but it's so awkward it
became too successful that we sort of
take it for granted and now we'll say oh
TV's collapse you go yeah but country
fast getting six million viewers you
know that's like it's a lot of people
you know and um I've so much of what I
know about the world and what people
like and politics and that comes from TV
and what people watch
nystigmas is that how you pronounce the
stagness yeah the stagness yeah stagmus
that's the condition you've had since
birth yeah
so you wouldn't you wouldn't know any
otherwise yeah exactly I've always um
you know my asset's always been blurry
and it's it's like an uncontrollable
moving of the the pupils I did once I
never used autocue on television so I
can't see it and once when I did have I
got news for you this because it's all
gags that are written you have to and I
was hosting they said well you're gonna
have to use it usually I can learn stuff
but that is a whole script worth of
games because I couldn't so the game
they said look this is the autocue that
Bruce uses so you'll be fine and even
that it wasn't big enough I said you've
got to move it nearer make it bigger in
the end we got it big enough uh but when
people were watching it they said oh is
Richard Osman drunk because they could
see the effort of having to focus on
something my eyes were going absolutely
crazy so people think you're drunk then
so I never hosted it I just went you
know what I'll be a guest where you know
I don't have to do and
I never use auto-q on any shows and
again that's one of those silly things
where what feels like a disadvantage is
a huge Advantage because you know so
many TV shows and we were talking just
before we came on air about about how
shows are edited and I'm thinking about
House of games I think about Dragon's
Den they're edited in in a very sort of
military way you know they've got the
same shots each time and the one thing
I've got control over is what I say and
the second something is on auto queue
you say the same thing because the
producers put the same thing in because
they've got other things to be worried
about and the fact that I don't have it
on auto security means I I just say
different things each time you know and
it's looser and it's Freer and people
can watch five episodes in a week and I
haven't introduced any of them in the
same way to the others and so I've
turned that thing of not being able to
see to an advantage which is you know I
present television shows differently in
a way that's hopefully a bit Freer and
feels a bit more natural
the other thing you talk about and I've
seen this in a few interviews is your
height being something you've almost
contended with and it's you know it's
interesting because
um
a lot of short men
want to be tall men and hear a tall man
say yeah speakers if you'd rather be a
little bit shorter is yeah it's quite
surprising well I'm six foot seven which
is too much is the truth uh and you know
it it makes you extraordinary look my
eyesight is not people can't see that
right okay so that's mine and that's
internalized and you know I deal with
that how I want to my height is
something that people can always see and
I find it I find it fascinating again in
this world of social media when when
people talk about microaggressions and
stuff that you must have seen your
entire life which is if you're different
in any way right you're reminded of it
non-stop you know mostly in a people
that are not being cruel sometimes they
are now I have a height so I'm not being
discriminated against because of my
height right it's not you know I'm not
it's not costing me anything but I do
know that every single day of my life
I'm reminded of it every single day just
non-stop and so I know that to be a
person of color to be differently
gendered to be all of these things I
know that the microaggressions I get you
are getting Non-Stop every day of your
life and in a much more harmful way so
I've always hopefully really really
understood the idea of microaggressions
and the idea that
please I hear this every single day even
if you're trying to be kind you know if
you see somebody as different they do
not need to be told they do not need it
pointed out every single day because
everyone has told them their entire life
that they're different you know and I
know you're just thinking yeah but it's
just me you think yeah but it's just you
and five other people every single day
forever and you know I've had that with
my height forever and ever and ever and
for incredibly self-conscious and most
people are perfectly nice some people
are horrible because some people it's a
really good radar for what people are
like
I call it a c word radar sometimes this
being different in any way and which
perhaps you'll agree with which is so
many people are sort of lovely and chat
but then you know a couple of times a
day there's just someone who wants to
shout you out of a window or just wants
to make you feel small ironically you
know that's what they want to do and you
just think why
someone's a bit different to you and
you've got to shout something and make
yourself feel a bit better you know and
so being different in any way whatsoever
I think really teaches you
about people and about the hate that's
out there and about the unhappiness
that's out there because that's where it
all comes from and so being tall yeah
has taught me about microaggressions and
and has made me try and fight for people
who are different and has made me just
say to people if someone is different
right just talk to them normally you
don't need to it's we never had the word
but sometimes I'll sort of tweet
something about oh I love this film or I
went to see this gig or blah blah blah
and like 10 people go glad I wasn't
behind you and you know what it's a
perfectly harmless joke right perfectly
harmless I get it I understand why
people do it
but I get it every single time someone
does it so just think for one second has
this guy ever heard this before has
heard this thing before is it a fun
thing to say to him because to me if I
go to Giga Cinema it's a nightmare
because I don't want to be in front of
anyone I go out of my way to be as far
back as possible which when you can't
see means it's impossible or you're
going to sit on the island and say yeah
take it seriously and every single time
they say it now that's just a tiny
example but recently people have said
they've started saying oh you mustn't
body shame I thought well that's
interesting because body shaming is sort
of something that um you know certain
people would say that all that that's
what a snowflake talking about body
shaming but actually it really I think
yeah
that's what you're doing that's what
people have done to me for the last 30
years they've body shame me like because
they've talked about my stature and I
felt ashamed
that's body shaming I mean that's what
that is I would never have thought of it
as that I just was embarrassed and just
made me feel shy maybe not want to go
out but it's body shaming and actually
having it named you just think oh good
for you and it's the younger generation
you do it they're so great and they're
just saying no come on that's body
shaming and you think oh that's such a
such a lovely sort of thing to have in
my Armory they're going to go yeah
that's exactly what you're doing uh and
again 90 of people they mean nothing by
it and I get it but it's just boring and
ten percent of people it's you just
think oh you're very unpleasant
I am I never I'm so glad to hear that
because it's really changed my
perspective because um and I mean
genuinely mean that like I wouldn't sit
here and just go yeah I agree I
genuinely have learned something yeah
and um
and I think I think it's I think it's
because of what how I phrase the
question at the start in the sense that
a lot of people feel a ton of Shame for
being slightly shorter which is again
it's uh it's it's a point point of being
different
um and I've never heard in my experience
someone say
but it's completely right that wherever
they go they must be continually
reminded of the fact that they're taller
than everybody and how that might might
make them feel when did that first start
happening in your life well sort of in
my teenage I was sort of very tall from
about 17 probably I was always tall but
kind of nice all you're the tallest in
your class and that's you know which is
quite a fun thing to be you know and
that's what you want you want to be six
two right that's what you know anyone
who's five nine or six seven we all want
to be six two uh and yes it's sort of 17
18 and when I was off to University
which again is very you know so I'm sort
of this guy who is Much Too Tall and is
awkward about being tall who can't see
anything and who's quite an introvert
anyway uh and so and I sort of had this
full self anyway from when he was nine
years old and his dad left and
everything was okay
um so you know there was a real sort of
storm of things Brewing there as I say
all of which have brought me good things
in the end but uh you know I think
um meant that you know I didn't I didn't
live the life I should have done for
many years because I was sort of hiding
away from things sometimes I have to
hide away from because with my eyesight
I just can't it's not safe for me to do
various things and some things just my
height and sort of thing I'm going to
look stupid oh I'm going to look stupid
going on a roller coaster thing and also
what if I cut what if my legs don't fit
on that and you know just silly silly
little things and
you know the world will not the world is
not shy and letting you know that you're
weird you know that there's something
weird about you and certainly that's
what I felt I felt weird and of course
as soon as you feel weird you have to
sort of
you know you live with it and your your
behavior sort of changes and you're
going to go oh no I am a weird person so
I have to hide that away or explain away
why I'm weird you know I'm very grateful
that the one thing I always had was I
was good with words I was able to put
things into words I was always able to
make people laugh uh and so I for years
I've been able to paper over the cracks
of all of that because I had all this
stuff but I knew that I could sit in a
room and make people laugh and I knew I
could say the right things to people and
and so I sort of I I got away with it
for years and years and years is the
truth
big one I have some exciting news this
episode is brought to you by
Mercedes-Benz who recently got in touch
to support the Diary of a CEO thank you
I've been quite the fan of their cars
for some time now so I jumped at the
chance to work with them as one of the
most well-known luxury Brands out there
and through getting to know their brand
on a much deeper level I came to learn
about our shared values on Innovation
striving to create a better tomorrow
some of you may know if you follow me on
Instagram that this year we invested in
a Mercedes-Benz of our own and honestly
it's transformed my life but not only
that we also use Mercedes-Benz to pick
up all of our guests on this podcast
this way the dire Visio experience
really starts from the moment they're
collected and we can be in total control
of how that introduction looks and feels
over the coming weeks I want to talk to
you about Mercedes EQ which is their
all-electric car range and how they're
Innovative Next Generation technology
and sustainable benefits are changing
the game in terms of their electric
driving for businesses but in the
meantime if you'd like to stay up to
date with the full range and find out
more about how Mercedes-Benz can work
for you and your business search
Mercedes-Benz Fleet and let me know how
you get on quick one from our longest
standing sponsor hero I I can't tell you
over the last I'd say over the last
really it's been about two and a half
years it was really um post pandemic how
much my health has become such a huge
priority in my life huel has been
probably the most important partner in
my health Journey because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it I trust the
brand to keep me nutritionally complete
and that is something that I fight for
every single day and the chaos and the
busyness of my life and that's why it's
such a wonderful thing to be able to
talk to this audience about a brand and
a product that is so unbelievably linked
to my values and the the place I am in
my life of valuing the gym exercise
movement my mind my breathing and all of
those things and most importantly my
nutrition that is the role fuel plays
and so if you haven't already tried Hill
and you've been resistant to my my
pestering then give it a go and let me
know how you get on you referred two
times now to this storm in your 20s
where kind of I guess this was the point
about your true north you must have
realized that you were far from your
true north and you needed to kind of
turn back or get across towards your
true north what was this storm in your
20s well I don't know it's it's an
interesting one really because you know
professionally I was doing the thing
that I loved you know I started working
Telly at 21 I haven't had a day off
since and you know I was being
successful because because I came from a
home where I watched TV and I was in an
industry full of people who didn't watch
TV it was very very easy for me to rise
through the ranks and to make shows and
to invent my own shows and to sell them
because you know I felt very very at
home uh and so I was being successful
and I was you know exactly producing
shows and and all sorts of things uh and
you know I had kids very young uh which
I'm delighted I I did because I'm 51 now
and they're like both in their 20s which
is amazing you know what my big
presenting issue was was was a was a
food addiction and and weird Behavior
around food which I wish I can sort of C
would be what a nine-year-old would have
would have set up for himself
and what'd you mean by that well I think
if you if you are going to be an addict
which is almost always how do I run from
this pain how do I run from the fact
that you know I'm not where where I need
to be when you're on nine food is
probably the only thing that's available
to you the food attachment maybe you
know there's there's only a certain
amount of things and a nine-year-old uh
has at their disposal Hot Wheels I mean
there's there's not a lot you can get
addicted to uh and so you know I I would
have addictive behaviors around food and
that I never sat and thought Oh
I've got a problem with my life I never
thought that I never thought oh you know
I'm I'm not who I'm supposed to be but
what I definitely thought was why why do
I have these eating behaviors that's
weird and in a way that explained my
weirdness away for me I mean you're
weird because because yet you have this
weird eating patterns that's the thing
that makes you weird and you think no
there's lots of things that make me
weird
um and so that's the thing that I went
to get help for you know so that's the
first time I went into therapy uh which
again from my background is not
something I would have considered but it
got to such a stage and I'm so tired of
this Behavior
of how weird it was and how dumb it made
me feel what was the behavior just
overeating and you know binge eating and
all that kind of just inability to
control food in any way whatsoever or if
I was controlling it just being
incredibly strict so either sort of
dieting or or being out of control with
food which is much more common than I
think we allow as a culture I think you
know alcoholism and drug addiction we
get we understand and this pathway is to
sort of uh getting better but I think
food addiction is is is is the sort of
last taboo but
you know I haven't spoken about it
before
the the messages I get from people just
saying yeah that's me or you know my
husband came into the kitchen and in
tears and just said that's that's me
that's been me for 20 years and that
that's the thing that I've got uh and
has never spoken about it to people so I
think I think it's really really really
uh common also why wouldn't it be you
know given the food industry right why
wouldn't it be why would why would a
food addiction not not be a thing and so
I think yeah those behaviors where you
just go do you know what I've got these
wonderful kids I've got this great
career and yet I'm still secretly eating
and feeling deeply ashamed of myself you
know what what's that right and after a
while you think maybe it's not the food
maybe it's me you know maybe the food is
a symptom of something rather than the
problem uh which of course is the case
you know booze is never the problem is
it drugs are never the problem that what
you're running from is the problem so
yeah I went to therapy and honestly from
the first session I did I I
that's my path to getting better and
you'll never not be an addict but that's
my path to kind of going okay I get it I
see I see what this is most people I
don't think will understand when you
when you say binge eating and overeating
I think a lot of people listening think
well I I overeat yeah yeah you know what
I mean but but what I've read from what
you described is a very very different
to just overeating a big meal once in a
while can you give me some detail as to
what you mean by yeah and again look
it's it's shaming for me to do so but
but a good example would be
I remember one of the first years with
us you know talking to the therapist
about it and and it was it was sort of
mid December so I wasn't going to see
him for a few weeks and he said look I
hope you know her Christmas day is not
too triggering because people eat so
much on Christmas day you know the
classic thing on Christmas day oh my God
you know all this and all the chocolates
and the crisps and we had a meal anyway
and then there's cheese at night and
blah blah and I said honestly I've eaten
like it's Christmas Day
every day
from my 20s and 30s that's not you know
that's what I've done when I'm in an
episode you know everything is like
Christmas Day I'm not eating because I'm
hungry I'm eating because the food is
there and because I need I need to not
be sitting by myself you know and
thinking about whatever I need to be
thinking about it so you know is that is
that idea is that it's it's that sort of
it's not oh aren't I naughty I had a
cream cake you know aren't I know it had
a cream cake and then I had the other
three and then 20 minutes later when
like there's even the tiniest amount of
space I went out and got some more food
you know it's that it's it's I mean it's
an addiction there's no other way of
putting it it's like having a bottle of
vodka then having another bottle of
vodka then having another bottle of
vodka it's the same thing uh and
the second you shine a light on it
listen some people listening will will
won't believe it exists that's by the
way absolutely fine you know it's listen
we believe what we believe I'm talking
to the people for whom this Behavior
might feel familiar that we've got
friends or relatives so whom this
Behavior might feel familiar it's real
you know it's a real thing uh and it's
quite hard to get your way out of
because you have to eat right but
there's ways through it and the first
way through it is to shine the light on
it and just say oh no no that's uh
that's me and to and to try and take
that shame away from it a bit when did
you realize that it was a in your own
words a strange Behavior because
I've got a friend who's been through a
similar well I've got two friends who've
been through very similar things
um one of them's I mean they're the two
close people and you know I know they've
both talked about it very publicly
um
one of which in a podcast one of which
does talks she talks about it all the
time on her Instagram and I've the two
closest people in my life went through
that and if one of them who again she's
talked about this publicly um that
resulted in bulimia
um and a bunch of other very uh
destructive eating patterns how did you
figure out that that it was different
well I think you you can't you know you
can you can fool everybody except
yourself you know finally and just you
know a lifetime you know when I was a
kid I would secretly eat and I would
find ways to get food and to be you know
and my mum would go oh where have all
those crisps gone that's weird and you'd
be like and you know then she started
hiding the Christian places because she
thought they kept going missing just
every
day of every month of every year since
then just just hunting down and finding
the food that I wanted uh and feeling
ashamed about it afterwards so I
I knew amongst the success I was having
and the friends I had and the lovely
time I was having with people I knew I
had this weird secret thing that wasn't
going away and that made me unhappy and
certainly made me unhealthy and that
probably at some point I was going to
have to do something about but it took
it took a long time I'm shocked about
how long it took before I finally went
do you know what this is I need to do
something about it but it's we often
understand how normal our behavior is by
comparison yeah were people saying
things to you like
like making little jokes and comments
and stuff like that no not really I mean
I could tell I was overweight but but
like most addicts you know you can it's
amazing how secret you can be about
things is the truth you know how you can
buy things in secret consume them in
secret lock yourself away uh you know
not be around people just so you can eat
um you know and plus of course don't
forget you can then go out for a pizza
with all your mates who were having
their one meal of the day and you've
been eating all day but you're thinking
great I get to have a pizza as well so
you know socially you can eat a lot as
well and then go home and eat more and
eat more convenience foods and and and
what have you
um so yeah I always knew
I always knew it was I always knew
something was wrong but again I think
probably
I'd added it to the list of things that
were weird about me that I'm tall and I
can't see and I got this weird food
thing so I just thought you know what
you're not really fit for this world is
the truth you know and you have all of
these things that are up with you so I
think I just put it in the list of
things I wasn't probably I wasn't built
to live the life that other people were
living and again of course these days
you realize everyone is everyone's not
built everyone goes home and does
something weird not everyone but you
know what I mean people so many people
have got their thing but I didn't know
that in in those days I didn't know I
just thought I was uniquely you know not
fit for these times being a kid born in
the 1970s from a working class
background as you've said is you know
the idea of therapy that the notion of
mental health is quite an alien one so
yeah that that day where you decide to
make the call to to a therapist
what's what's going through your head on
that day
honestly I was I was I was really ready
for it is the truth I wasn't even kind
of
I wasn't even I was I was praying that
it was going to work rather than
thinking it wasn't going to work and
from the second I walked in
this guy called Bruce and he's brilliant
and he you know he said talk me through
the problem just you know and I said oh
blah blah blah this is the problem and
I'm you know overreaching but you know
maybe it's okay because you know but you
know so I was giving it all this and I
was saying but actually it's sort of
fine because you know I'm I'm doing this
and you know I'm uh I can I can control
it uh and let me talk for about 10
minutes and he just said um and how's
that all working out for you and he
thought yeah well you're right it's
working out terribly for me and from
that moment he had me I just thought
okay let's go on this journey and like a
personal trainer you just think okay I
trust you you know absolutely you've
seen it all before uh you understand all
of these things you can use my
cleverness to your benefits uh and it's
just been a I'm so immensely grateful
for everything that he's done and the
wisdom he's shown me and one of the
things I try and do in the books and in
everywhere is is try and pass that on
because I was lucky enough to be able to
afford this guy who's not you know he's
not insanely but it's difficult to find
a therapist
and part of my job is the only bit of
wisdom he passes to me is I try and pass
on because that's
I feel like that's something that I can
do and try and give people that the
thing that I've been given what are some
of those ideas that he those kind of
unlocking were there because I'm
thinking I assume there was like some
bit of Eureka moments where someone says
something you've kind of you detailed
one there where he says well how's that
working out for you yeah were there any
like thoughts that he's given you that
Bruce has given you that you can that we
can all apply to our lives that will
help us understand ourselves better or
free ourselves from whatever we've
imprisoned ourselves with yeah I think I
think his key thing is is this idea of
Shame and the things that make us feel
ashamed uh because
here's the thing
if you start feeling ashamed you then
start feeling ashamed of being ashamed
in the same way anyone's ever had a
panic attack would tell you you should
stop panicking you then Panic about
panicking or if you start feeling
anxious you're then anxious about your
anxiety uh and that's the absolute thing
you have to stop that's the cut off so
if you're feeling shame or you're
feeling Panic or you're feeling anxiety
let it be okay stay for a reason it's
looked after you for many years okay and
that which is another thing you've got
to make peace with this way that you've
tried to protect yourself through shame
or through Panic or anxiety right just
let it be what it is and once you do
that
it burns itself out and listen it'll
come back tomorrow and it'll come back
the next day but what it doesn't do is
spire on a spiral and a spiral and lead
you to self-medicate you know if you can
just let shame be what it is if you can
let panic or anxiety or however you
experience what it is however you
experience the thing where you just
realize that this ain't right you know
this is not who I want to be or how I
want to be whatever that feeling is for
you let it be what it is for a while
because it's not going away anytime soon
you know if you want regime change right
that's slow you know that's that boots
on the ground you know it's bit by bit
so let it be what it is allow it shine a
light on it and he'd always say
you know if you're in a moment of Shame
and you can become conscious about it in
some way right so say I've just eaten
some food and I'm feeling ashamed about
it because I just sitting there and just
thinking that was so dumb why have I
done this again uh have a conversation
with yourself he said right now that
conversation that's you talking to you
okay the both of both of those bits are
perfectly valid now one bit is the one
that's harmful to you that's you and the
other bit is the bit that's trying to
save you that's you as well and the key
thing is is just stop practicing the
muscles on the one that's trying to save
you you know just give it a bit more Air
Time Each time let's give it a few more
arguments each time the other one's
never going away and it never will any
addict to tell you that's never going
anywhere it's power and some days it's
like so powerful you know but you have
to let the other side of the argument
you've got to give it some strength
you've got to send it to the gym you
know and that's that's the thing it's
it's saying you're always going to have
this right because most people's
addictive behaviors or whatever it is
come from childhood and come from a self
that we built up all almost always to
protect ourselves from something okay so
you have to love it a bit you have to
love this thing that you set up to
protect yourself but also you have to
talk to it and when you're talking to it
you have to understand
that there's two sides of yourself and
you've got to build up the one that's
talking to it you've just got to build
it and build it and build it and give it
strength and it's hard to do and you'll
find different ways of doing it and
different people will find different
ways but just remembering that the one
that's saying
hold on maybe I shouldn't have a drink
you know that that is equally valid as
someone who's saying I should have a
drink the one who's saying you should
have a drink it's got a point of course
it's got a point you know it kind of
works for you it numbs things you know
listen you wouldn't do it if it hadn't
worked you know and you like it uh so
that's it's valid but this other one is
also valid and maybe maybe listen to it
a bit more often and just give it a bit
more air time and then over the years
you might find that it's got more power
than the other one is that what you
found yeah I I found it and listen it's
really really hard is the truth uh and I
get it with alcoholics and drug addicts
you you can just cut off drinking booze
and and taking drugs it's incredibly
difficult and I see the struggles that
people have with it and again it's a
lifelong thing and every day you think
of please today just let me drink today
I would love to have a drink you know
you'll never meet an alcoholic who
wouldn't just love to have a drink today
um and with food you do have to eat so
you have to you have to put in a
slightly more different set of rules but
you know you just have to give yourself
boundaries and know that you mustn't
cross those um those boundaries but yeah
I think that honestly shining a light on
things is the thing talk to people about
it talk to people you love you know
you'll be shocked and I was shocked when
I opened up to people and the people
closest to me I opened up and they went
yeah of course of course I know of
course I know that uh but once they know
about it
they can help you know and that's very
powerful and it's very very important
and then you know it's it's nice for me
to be able to speak publicly about it
because I do think
probably there aren't enough male role
models saying that food can be difficult
and food can be an issue
um and so I'm happy to be one I'm sort
of not I'm embarrassed don't get me
wrong it's embarrassing for me to talk
about I've absolutely put that on the
record you know I'd rather not be
talking about it but the things that
come from it are more powerful and the
more I talk about it the less power it
has over me and hopefully the more I
talk about it the the less parent might
have over other people
one of the things I've learned from
sitting here with with people from all
walks of life that have been through a
variety of different traumases um I used
to think that we could cure this stuff
like we could go to therapy we could
read this thing read this quote spin
around tap our head and it's gone yeah
and I've come to learn that that's it's
never gone yeah I now I almost feel my
head is almost the scales and if you
what you're trying to do is in fact make
the allow the decision to be made by the
the better side yeah but the the trauma
or the the beliefs that you've built as
a child about the world and yourself and
your relationships whatever is always
going to be there and it can be
triggered and then flared like a flame
with oxygen I I think that's it and the
key is not to panic when it when it
rears its head again the key is never to
think oh I'm never going to be rid of it
the key is to go oh I'm never going to
be rid of it that's the thing as soon as
the second you go oh it's always going
to be there it's very freeing because
you kind of go okay listen every now and
again it's going to flare up but I don't
need to panic I don't need to go all
this work I've done all this work I've
done on myself all these books that I've
read and it's still there it hasn't gone
away and the second you go it's staying
right it's like a sofa you don't like in
your living room right it's not going
anywhere okay you just have to learn to
live with it you know sometimes you can
look around you don't even notice the
sofa anymore and sometimes you go oh my
God look at that sofa right it is
staying and if if you it gives you a lot
of power to know that it's staying and
and that when it's in charge which it
will be sometimes uh that it's okay just
to go now listen just let it let it do
its thing and the one thing that that
addictive part of your personality wants
you to do is panic you know that's the
one thing it wants because that's where
it thrives you know it thrives on the
chaos that's what it wants it wants you
to be off balance so you have to sort of
occasionally just go
I get it you're in charge for a few days
or for a week or so or a month uh you do
your thing I'm going to try and just
live in good faith in the rest of my
life and and and just sort of let you
burn out
20 years in the in the TV business
roughly yeah is it 20 yeah so it was 30
really
TV business now which I was sometimes I
forget I am
that's a long time to be in TV tell me
tell me about that phase of your career
and really like what it um
what I guess the question my the
question I wanted to ask you is how come
you were so successful in TV and no one
ever likes blowing you know smoke up
they're an ass or whatever but
um
you were very very successful you you
produced some unbelievable formats that
you know
go beyond luck or chart you know so in
hindsight why why you well I love uh
well it's a good question I mean I love
and one I feel more comfortable talking
about now I've sort of I've sort of
stepped off that that Carousel now I
think that I loved television
you know and I loved seeing what
entertained people and I've got quite
mainstream tastes so I it was in my DNA
I wasn't having to leave University go
into television and think right what do
people like I never I've never ever ever
had to go into work and say what do
people like right I sort of know
that something I like enough people will
like that it's a TV show so I've always
loved that I've always loved creativity
I've always loved you know sitting down
with a pen and paper and knocking things
into shape and I've always loved sport
and the formats of sport and Knockouts
and stuff like that so in Jeopardy
that's very very natural to me as well
uh but then I also
for reasons I've known to me I love
sales I love selling you know I
absolutely love going and I'm pitching
and the thing I love about it is working
at what people want and why uh and how
they're going to respond and how to give
them the thing that they want and so
that combination of I would come up with
things I was proud of
uh and then I would try and sell them
and you know that's the thing that's the
thing that that I love if I've had any
success it's been
thinking of ideas that I would like to
watch and then packaging them in such a
way that someone at Channel 4 or the BBC
will give you four million quid for it
which is a big ask you know selling a TV
show is quite a big ask it's like being
a car salesman you know you don't need
to sell that many cars to be successful
you know and the TV is the same way
you've just got to make sure that you've
got the best car out there uh and so
yeah I think I think a mix of the
introversion of loving sitting down and
working things out and working out
formats and then the the extra version
of being able to say to people I think
this is really going to work for your
channel you know those two things
together have always
driven me I'm creatively I'm incredibly
ambitious I love to create new things
and in business terms I'm also
incredibly ambitious which is I like to
build value and I like to make money for
people there's two thoughts there which
in my head almost sit in Conflict one of
them is I make things that I would love
to watch and then figuring out what
other people want
well that's the thing is I've never
really I've never bothered thinking
about what what people want and I think
the second you do that that's a lie
actually when so in endemall which which
I ran with with a group of people for
many years after big brother and various
things there was a point probably sort
of 2006 2007 where we got so huge and so
powerful that we could sort of sell
anything if that makes sense or not that
we could send anything but people are so
desperate to have product from us that
they were buying substandard things so
you know there's a couple of times where
I went in and we sold shows that
actually I was thinking I don't know
about this and it's very rare that I
would go to a pitch meeting thinking I
don't know about this one but they would
buy it in the room and then you go and
then you've got to make it and guess
what it's really hard to make because no
one cares no one watches it because they
can tell it's not doesn't come from
anyone's heart so you don't get a second
series and TV business is all about
second series and third series you make
no money from from the first series so
I've definitely been in rooms where I
picked stuff that I didn't care about uh
but every time this and you can't you
really care about and you can sell and
then you will give it your absolute best
shot making it because I sort of I know
how to make it because this this is the
thing I want to watch it was like books
I wrote books that I would like to read
that I didn't see out there and with TV
programs it's just oh my God you'd have
an idea in the morning just go I would
love to watch that I would love to watch
that then you sit down you Workshop it
you work it out and then you go and
Pitch it and you know that was my entire
career I never really got involved too
much in the in the in in the in the real
business side side of things and you
know in exploitation and rights and
foreign sales and distribution and all
of that I was just sat in a creative Hub
really just coming up with ideas just
sort of feeding the engine and I was
able to do it because I was sort of be
doing it anyway I would be I would sit
at home and do that if I wasn't in that
office I would be thinking this is a
thing I would love to see on TV and I
was just lucky enough to be in an
environment where I could have an idea
on a Tuesday and we could set it on a
Thursday
and it comes from
I loved it but the second the second new
second guess yourself or the public I'll
go what would people like I don't I
don't buy it I don't buy it when people
write books like that I don't buy it
when people make TV programs like that
and I'm surrounded by people in that
industry early on not so much at
Enderman where we were TV lovers but
earlier on where I was it was full of
people who were just in it for the
lifestyle and it didn't watch Telly
there's people even now who don't watch
Telly you just think come on do
something else
what is creativity to you then so so you
know you've described a few things there
but what at its Essence what is
creativity and how does one can one go
about being more creative or becoming
more creative yeah it's it's a it's a
tricky one that because it's always it's
it's always just been the way that my
brain has worked I was talking to um
husband of a friend of mine who's a
who's a who's A working class french guy
who is a maths genius this case I grew
up in the bandure of Paris uh and at
about 11 years old gets plucked out of
the school system and taken to this like
a call for mathematicians because he's a
genius and since has made a fortune in
the city right there's algorithms right
that's it's in trading algorithms right
because it's the maths uh as I was
talking to him I hope we were on holiday
recently and I said um
so you just you come up with stuff
that's new that other people haven't
spotted it's like he's yeah he does a
French I won't do his accent it's very
almost comically French uh and he was
saying yeah that's that's exactly what I
do and I say how do you experience that
I said because I know how I experience
it and I experience it there's five or
six clouds of things going around the
outside of my head at any given time
something I've Just Seen On TV something
I just read in the newspaper something
something somebody said to me something
my mum said to me uh something that's
happened at home five different things
and occasionally two of those things
will bump into each other
and you go whoa I never thought of that
before and so without saying that I said
how do you experience creativity and he
said well I just I got all these
Concepts sort of they sort of rush
around the outside of my head and
occasionally two of them will bump into
each other or three of them are bump
into each other and suddenly I've got
something new and that's how I've always
experienced creativity now
is that useful to people I don't know
other than to say keep your eyes open
and your ears open all the time and be
listening to the world just see how the
world is spinning see how it's working
and sometimes there is if you're in TV
it's seeing how a particular television
program works that's sort of a very
direct bit of copying but almost always
it's then you're on the bus and someone
says something to their kid or someone's
late for school and they're running and
you kind of go wait a minute that
reminds me of something so it's it's
eyes open ears open all the time and
just let allow things to bump into each
other I would say there's a point
there's another piece there which I've
just noticed from you saying this which
is I love the analogy of the clouds so I
was thinking okay so I need more clouds
in my life which is more points of
inspiration and then the second thing is
well there's loads of people have got
loads of clouds but they don't have the
intent to connect the clouds which is
like you have a uh you've designed a
life where you have you actually have
commitments to make the to when the
clouds bounce to turn it into something
a lot of people's clouds are bouncing
and they're just going oh look the
clouds just hit each other yeah I think
that's probably I've never thought about
I think that's incredibly wise two
different things here firstly increase
the number of clouds yeah which is
increase the amount of people if you
want to be creative by the way you don't
have to be it's overrated uh but
increase the amount of clouds increase
the data points that are coming into you
you know the people you're seeing or you
know just go and do something different
go and learn Japanese whatever it is
something that gives you a different
cloud and then yeah it's
I guess yeah professionally they've had
to be bumping into each other for month
for my whole life so it's completely
natural to me but yeah if you can force
yourself sometimes to to to sort of
think of the things that have gone
around you here think of the things that
happened to you today think of the
things you watch think about a film you
just saw and why you liked it or a film
you just saw and why you didn't like it
you know think about an argument you
just had with your mum and what she said
and why it's annoying uh and you know
it's the same argument you keep having
is there any way of fixing that in a
different way to just keep those clouds
going and then you know occasionally let
them just sort of intersect and that's
yeah I think by and large that's where
ideas come from you know and it's you
talk about it a lot on this podcast as
well hard work is also a thing yeah you
know actually putting the hours in you
know it's all very well to go oh and
they just had the idea on the bus and
then I came in but you only have the
idea on the bus because you spent four
hours the previous day with a blank
piece of paper in the office just saying
oh God I got nothing you know because
that's dislodging so many things in your
head so you yeah you you have to you
have to work on it and then okay
recently occasionally the gods give you
a little gift
I've thought so much you know because I
think
um I think we're all artists in some
respect in our own way whether it's
blogging or DJing or if it's writing or
making TV I think that and I also think
expression is it's almost therapy for us
yeah so I really I really I've got
behind this idea over the last year of
like we all have our own form of Art and
when we express ourselves it's good for
our minds so the the advantage that I
think me and you've both had is we've
been in careers where that art has been
monetized or there's been a real reward
for it so it comes so there's an
incentive to drive it out of us but if
you're for someone driving a lawyer up
and down this country or walking the dog
this morning before they go and you know
go and go and work their job in a
factory or you know I see all of the
tags we get on a Monday when the
episodes come out
how do they go about creating that
incentive to to when the clouds to
connect to turn it into something or to
even write it on a piece of paper you
know yeah you you're quite right we both
have very short routes to monetization
yeah but I sense that's important to
both of us yeah as well and so we we've
probably sort that out you know and
found found a career where that where
that happens and it's interesting if
you're a lorry driver the greatest
invention of the 20th century the thing
that changed the world more than any
other invention is the Lorry driver who
when he was sort of dropping off his
load at the docks in Boston and you know
he's got all the kind of stevedores
taking everything out the back of his uh
you know Lorry and then putting it in
another sort of a big container to put
on the ship just went what if the
container on the back of my lorry
was the same container that went on the
ship you know and what if you take that
off and you take the container from the
ship and you put it back on my Lorry and
then I drive it back down to San
Francisco what if you did that and he
invented the technology for you know the
container crates as we see them now and
opened up all of World Trade right
that's one Lorry driver just having one
idea on one day you know and absolutely
change the world so there's no
Industries where
you can't be creative because if you're
a lorry driver you really really know
your business right and you know uh
what causes delays you know when your
work is harder you know the five minutes
you can knock off here there or the
other you know when you turn up at a
place the paperwork you have to go
through you know that three of those
forms could be two forms you know you
know that if people knew you were
arriving 10 minutes earlier you could
leave half an hour earlier because you
know break patterns can be changed you
know all of that stuff and so work on
that if that's the industry you want to
stay in and if you want to make TV
programs or write books or write Social
Media stuff then just consume it a lot
you know and I just think you can only
be creative in an area you're interested
in that's the truth you cannot be
creative in an area not interested it
just doesn't that's not how creativity
works because creativity has to sort of
be buzzing around all the time and be
and be curious so work out what it is
you're interested in and then surround
yourself with it as much as you can it's
hard with you if you're if the area
you're interested in is not your job
because that's something you have to do
in your own time but if it's something
you're serious about and you're curious
about and you have the abilities then
just yeah think about exactly what you
said which is intent which is
surrounding yourself by by more things
uh and then you know making those
connections
the the intentionality I'm always trying
to understand because it links back to
what you've done with your books which
have been just the most insane Smash Hit
I've ever encountered in the studio
um with with TV formats how intentional
how much is there sort of I don't even
know if intentionalities but
intentionality versus like
um luck and chance and Serendipity yeah
because you've seen this for your entire
career yeah so how much can you predict
the success of these things oh you can
never predict funny enough deal on ideal
which you just mentions the only show
where after the pilot I thought this was
a hit I thought there's no way this show
is not going to be a hit and it was a
huge hit but it's the only time and
there's been shows I've done before
where I think oh this has got a good
chance and they've disappeared and shows
where I thought I don't know about this
and they've been huge you know you can't
tell at all and that's why it's
important to trust yourself and do stuff
that you love so the intentionality is
that
if I put a lot of work into something
and a book is the hardest I've ever
worked on anything if I put a lot of
work on something I want the upside if
it works to be you know I want there to
be an upside if it works you know I want
if I do this properly I want there to be
no limit to what can happen with it you
know because I like output for in you
know if I put in input I like output to
come out and with TV it's sort of easier
because as I say you can you can invent
something on Tuesday and set it on
Thursday with a book you've got to spend
two years and so all the way through I
sort of thought if I do this well I
think this has got a chance so my my
sort of creative mainstream brain was
thinking that I wasn't thinking I need
to make it more like this I need to make
it more like that I 100 wrote the book I
wanted to write but as I was writing I
think you know if you do this properly
if this property hits then people will
really like it uh if no one had bought a
single copy or if I'd showed it to an
agent and she just said this is not for
us that would have been fine too by the
way because I'd written it and that's
creativity in and of itself is is a
thing you know you can paint painting in
your attic and it's like the Mona Lisa
because you did it but the fact that
when it did come out people liked it was
uh yeah that I'd say was a huge bonus I
read a quote and it said um there's a
reason why
great
um great books become blockbuster movies
but blockbuster movies never become
great books and he says one of them is
written by committee and one of them is
written by a solo author with their own
ideas and Inspirations and I remember
thinking that [ __ ] that's so true yeah
that's interesting JK Rowling yourself
you know yeah and Bill bug bought your
book he has bought the book yeah what
the rights of the book I hope you bought
the actual book as well you never know
uh no it's true and listen publishing is
a very interesting industry having come
out of Television I know you had a big
hit book and it's a very very this is
mine was a pebble in the ocean but it's
an interesting industry and if you bring
any sales techniques into the world of
books it's like I think there's a slight
shock to their system and and and and
it's a very very you know I love it it's
such a nice kind friendly industry but
you know I come at it from a TV angle
which is you know I'm
TV you look at the overnight service and
there's millions and you know that's
what I've always judged things on and
and and and in books it's a slightly
different market so I've loved being
able to apply some of the things I know
and some of the techniques I know so the
book itself listen like with anything
you have to be proud of it and I'm so
proud of these books I love them okay
that's the that's the absolute base
point of all of this but once we've got
that I've loved the selling process
which I think a lot of authors don't
love I love it I love the marketing
process I've got something I'm really
proud of I want as many people as
possible to read it that's what I want I
want as many people as possible to enjoy
this book I want to entertain as many
people as possible uh and that's a
process that I've loved and a process I
think publishing is not quite set up for
is the truth and it's it's been fun sort
of find it finding a way through that
and when you wrote this book you didn't
you wrote it all before you'd showed
anybody from what I understand yeah the
first book yeah the first one because
well because only because I'm on telly
and you know that thing of celebrity
authors and you know it'll be easy to
write a chapter and say would you like
to publish it and of course it would you
know because then again you don't have
to sell a whole lot of books to make
make a profit in that industry so I
thought I thought I think that they
would just say yes and I wouldn't have
any clue if it's any good so I I wrote
the whole thing just to because I wanted
to prove that it was a good book sent it
to an agent who I trust very very much
who comes from a very similar background
to me uh and I said listen you've got to
look me in the whites in the eyes and
tell me would you represent this book if
I wasn't on TV and she said listen I
would 100 easy for her to say but she
did uh and then before just as it was
going out to um the Publishers in the UK
we sold it immediately in Germany right
and Germany is a big Market Germany they
love crime fiction and from that moment
I just thought oh okay I can now I sort
of believe I liked the book but of
course you know well sometimes I hated
it and sometimes I liked it but I
thought I think it's got something but
the second Germany bought it in Germany
I have no idea who I am do you know
couldn't care less who I am and they
bought the book just on the strength of
the manuscript and I thought from that
moment do you know what everything now
I'm just gonna go full steam ahead
because someone who doesn't know I'm a
celebrity has just bought this book and
it's probably and it's been top 10 in
Germany for like two years it's like
it's like non-stop out there and they
don't know who I am I'll go out there
and do press and they're like they have
no idea who Am they just know the books
uh and yeah so I was glad that I kept it
secret because I never had that worry of
are people just publishing this because
of who I am because I I could see
straight away from other territories
that people who had no idea who I am and
Spielberg again within I mean with only
literally only just sold in so you know
there'd be no hoopla no announcements
and he bought the rights immediately
because he'd read it and liked it and he
didn't know who I was
so that from that moment I just thought
I have the right now to really put my
foot down on the accelerator and and
sell this because I because I because I
believe in it you said sometimes you
loved it sometimes you hated it you talk
to me about doubt and as it relates to
your creative work of your career
generally well I think I think I mean
anyone who's sitting at home and writing
a book right now uh you know half the
time you're just thinking what is this
this is absolute nonsense or you know
this is that wouldn't happen or you just
no one's going to be interested in this
story
um and you know I still think I thought
it would book two and book three both
when they came out I just thought oh no
I think maybe you lost it and then the
reaction is is sort of reassures you uh
each time um listen I'll lose it at some
point
um
yeah it's it's it's impossible to to you
know I'll read it I'll read back scenes
the next day and you know something will
make me cry I'll make me laugh or
there'll be a nice line I think oh that
that's that's something but you're so
close to a book that if you were
thinking it was good something's up you
know you have to think it's awful
because
you know it's like
it's never going to be the the beautiful
shiny thing that's in your head you know
when when I'm writing the fourth one at
the moment and in my head I know that I
know the story and it's so you would not
believe how gleaming it is and how
intricate and beautiful and like
perfectly crafted and toned it is and I
know that the thing I handed in what I
handed will not be that you know because
there'll be compromises and they'll make
mistakes and there'd just be stuff
that's wrong so I'll always be comparing
it to the thing that's in my head you
know and everyone every writer in their
head has the perfect novel it's all up
there and the thing you you you you give
is is not that thing but the key with
the key with novels I think is if people
are engaged with your characters and
love your characters and the nice thing
isn't that this but people people the
characters speak to people which is
which is great if people love your
characters then the rest is just craft
the rest is just getting the story down
you know the rest is just sort of
putting them on a journey because the
people that love your characters and
they care what happens to them so you
can make stuff happen then and you know
that the stuff that you make happen
people will care about quick one I'm
both extremely honored and excited to
announce our brand new sponsor for this
podcast American Express I pretty much
use my American Express business
Platinum Card daily so many benefits it
comes everywhere with me it's an
absolute no-brainer there's now a new
range of benefit the first benefit is
that you get 10 000 bonus points each
month on top of what you're already
earning when you spend ten thousand
pounds per month and those points are
then exchanged for rewards for anything
from holidays to flights to Tech to
designer purchases and finally the one
that's had a real impact for me and our
team is you can make use of their
company expense management tool Amex
expense it's free to use Simple to set
up and even integrates with your
accounting software which our finance
team are very happy about so with that
said if you'd like to find out more
about how you can get hold of American
Express's business platinum card then
search American Express business
platinum card and if you've already got
a business Platinum Card let me know how
you get on when you look back at this
success of this book we talked earlier
about these clouds that you kind of
piece together what are the clouds that
you connected in order to produce this
book yeah it's well a number a number of
classes a love of crime fiction that's a
good that and that just sort of vibe
that idea that I sort of love
a puzzle and I think so just that's that
kind of thing of that that's an itch
that's kind of thing I would I would
like to do it then I had um
an idea about a a former civil servants
pulling off a massive bank heist
uh and there was a former civil servant
who who worked in a very boring job in
the civil service but it was so boring
that people assumed that uh he was a spy
because no one's job can be that boring
so you work in Whitehall I bet you're a
spy and he wasn't he was just a
logistics guy and so I had that idea and
I'd had it for ages just this older guy
who've got this plan that he wanted to
to pull off and then my mum lives in a
retirement community Retirement Village
down in Sussex and I was just down there
and just looking around I think I said
well this would be an amazing place for
a murder you know like Agatha
christie-esque and suddenly those things
have look you want to write a book and
you had that idea about that the
Silverstone all sort of spy who had this
sort of big plan and then you thought ah
there's this there's this place and this
group of people that they're they're all
a bit older and this place would be
perfect for a murder and then in that
Community they have every day there's
all sorts of different clubs this French
conversation Club on a Tuesday you know
Wednesday art history and literally the
name Thursday Murder Club came into my
head with another the cloud all the
clouds come together they go into your
brain and you just think okay let's
start tomorrow because when the clouds
come together in the right way when the
things connect together in the right way
you sort of
it's interesting you sort of you kind of
press your foot down like to see if it
holds it's like it's like a sort of
plank of wood has suddenly appeared
underneath you or like a little rope
Bridge has appeared and you sort of
tread on the first plank of word you
think oh that's
quite solid that plank of wood and then
you step on the next one you think oh
that's solid and you step on the next
one and most ideas by the third or
fourth plank your foot goes through they
think oh yeah of course I can't do that
because XYZ but sometimes and you'll
have experienced this sometimes you keep
walking on the planks of wood and you're
like I mean these are these are sodded
all the way to the other side this feels
like I'm going to walk across this
bridge you know I'm just gonna I'm gonna
take up the chance I'm gonna walk across
this bridge and you know that that's
that that's what happened really and
that's that's how and that also is how I
experience new ideas and creativity is
that the idea of you just try and put a
bit of weight on them and it holds you
put a bit more weight and it holds and
you know if it keeps holding then it's
it's worth persevering with I've been
through a really interesting um Journey
with some of my ideas where I've thought
of an idea tested the planks all very
solid I've got very close to doing it
and then my gut has just gone down to it
because like you know yeah and then I've
had obviously as I said many other ideas
where I've had an idea that wake up the
next day I think oh God get that on the
shelf and it's funny you know it's funny
how you can go on a quite an emotional
Journey a conviction Journey with an
idea and at the very last minute you can
go do you know something's just not
right here but I'll tell you the other
reason for that I think is because you
because you have walked the walk and
you've built businesses and you know you
know what it takes you also sort of know
if you press the green light on an idea
amen there's a huge amount of work ahead
of you and responsibility and you
sometimes you just think I am not
prepared to do that there's not enough
upside in this for me creative or
whatever it is for me to do it uh and
that's the same I know for example that
idea like a novel I knew two years
before I wanted to write it but I just
didn't I knew I didn't have the I knew
what it would take and with the social
media idea I know at the moment it would
be all consuming and that's not where I
am you nailed it that's exactly what
what happens I get right to the point of
pressing the button and then I'm staring
the cost in its face the cost I've known
so well yeah this thought of okay this
is going to be five years and everything
which and when I think of cost now I
think okay that means my relationship
with my partner is going to get
something can be worse relationship with
my friends getting worse all my
businesses are going to see less of me
and is that really worth it and what is
the upside there yeah but it's exactly
that but again that's not something you
worry about at 21 at 21 you just think
you're great Bring it on Bring it on and
now you you know you have the luxury of
you know you and that's the idea thing
about having 10 ideas the sooner or
later one will come along you just think
hold on I really like it it feels
monetizable
it's not going to take up a massive
amount of my time because of the way
it's structured and you know my my
relationship will will survive and my
friendship will survive and I've still
got this thing that I'm gonna love and
you just you just have to sit and wait
for that idea to come along because you
know you can't no one wants no one wants
to be that guy is working 24 hours a day
their whole life because it's honestly
the truth is it's not that hard to
succeed if you're willing to you know do
everything and to work 24 hours you know
it's not
is doable with an idea and hard work but
that's not that's not how your life
should be so the success of this book
you know there's there's a monetary
element to it you're not you don't have
an expensive taste so that's not really
moved you much there's the the kind of
validation of your own create singular
Creative Vision which has been validated
sincerely how has it impacted your
happiness at all
um I think you know what I think it's I
think it's a reflection of my happiness
rather rather than a sort of a source of
my happiness I think it's a book that I
have only been able to write from a
happy place and from a place where I
feel comfortable with my demons and
comfortable with myself and uh you know
I think it comes from that so you know
the characters
uh the four main characters all of him
are sort of like quadrants of my own
brain uh I think you can tell that I
love those characters and they love each
other and that's probably not something
I could have written 10 15 years ago
that comes from happiness or it comes
from it comes from self-acceptance you
know it comes from I am there's bits of
myself I'm very prepared to sort of put
out there uh uh to entertain and to to
you know uh so I think I think it's I
think it comes from happiness rather
than being the source of it uh obviously
it brings me an enormous amount of joy
and it's a load of fun and it's fun that
it's a hit in other countries so you get
to go abroad and you know talk to them
about it and you know uh that's fun but
yeah and you know in this book the third
one there's you know there's there's
lots of there's there's lots of love
there and I'm getting married this year
and so it's it's all little things where
you just think the books listen they're
crime stories so there's murders and
they're you know this you know this red
herrings and there's Clues and all sort
of stuff so that that sort of it's got
that Agatha Chris thing but the spirit
of the book is hopefully a spirit that
can that can only come from having you
know having found some happiness with
yourself
what what is happiness to you because
it's such a it's such a small simple
word to describe so much yeah and it's
yeah it's it's a it's a really tricky
one I'm the key thing is is to know that
you can't be happy all the time you know
it's not like a kind of you wake up
every morning with a huge smile on your
face you know there's still going to be
parking tickets you know and the drains
are still going to be blocked you know
and there's so that you know there's
just there's always going to be trouble
I think it's a I think it's a am I am I
content with myself
um am I when I sort of close the door
and I'm with either my partner or by
myself
do I feel contentment do I feel there's
a nagging I think I've had years and
most people do just there's nagging
questions all the time it's just
something or something's not right or am
I in the right place or uh and just that
feeling that no hold on I think I think
I'm in the right place which I think you
have when you're a really little child
and I think probably we lose over the
years and if we're very very lucky
um and yeah you have to fight to regain
that which is I feel happy and safe and
secure and that I'm in the right place
are there any questions still
for oh goodness yeah of course there are
I mean my one you know I I want I've
always as I say because I don't see so
well and because I'm tall I've always
been a Observer of life I've always been
an outsider but I've never really got my
hands dirty is the truth uh and you know
I see I see the problems of the world
and I you know I I try and help
financially and all that kind of stuff I
try and do good things you know I've
never really got my hands dirty and I
think probably in the next decade I
should get my hands dirty a little bit
um you know just helping and you know
making people's lives a little bit
easier uh that's the thing and that's
the thing I've always been frightened of
uh well because because uh you know I've
I never really took part in life quite
so much as other people because of my
height and because of my eyesight
because all of those things I always
felt I needed to be on the sidelines and
I needed to just commentate and I've
been very really happy doing that by the
way I'm an introvert I love I love I
love to do it but I do think you have a
responsibility to leave the world a
better place and you found it listen
there's not much point to us being here
but if we've got anything is to do that
is to sort of say well look for whatever
reason I was put on this Earth You know
the one thing I can do is try and leave
it in a better State and so that that's
I think my the question for the next 10
20 years that sort of service what can I
do how can I help what about any
personal questions you have about
yourself and your your um you know
you've talked a lot about not feeling
especially when you were younger not
feeling like you were right for the wild
or that you fit in the world do you have
any of those personal questions left
remaining no I think you know I do think
that I'm probably not quite fit them
right for the world but I think lots of
us do I think that's the that's the
thing you know the world is a it's a
weird place I mean it's weird that we're
here right I mean it's odd right it's
peculiar and it doesn't make it it makes
no sense we can look for a higher
purpose if we want and that's great but
even with that
it's weird right and it's weird that we
have this civilization it's weird that
we have this Consciousness it's weird
that we're millions and billions of
people around the globe or you know in
different countries all thinking
slightly different things with slightly
different consciousnesses it's weird you
know it's it life makes no sense uh and
so the key is to stop trying to find the
answer to what is life because that's
not something you're ever going to find
uh and and I think the question is is is
how can I you know how can I help either
how can I help if you find yourself in a
position of power or how can I ask for
help if you find yourself in a position
where you don't have power and those are
two very difficult things to do these
are questions that I I think could only
come from an introvert yeah I think
that's I think I think that's probably I
I think I'm quite an alpha introvert I
will say that uh but yeah listen I I
love going home and shutting the door
and that's my favorite thing family at
home two kids yeah well they're not at
home anymore yeah yeah early twenties
yeah 24 and 22. wow yeah crazy right do
you ever worry that because of that uh
that what happened with your father that
you're I'm you talked about your your
first marriage didn't work out do you
ever have concerns or worries like
because I often wondered when we've had
like somewhat dysfunctional homes how we
then either continue the cycle or
sometimes it seems that people go very
much the opposite way and really put
measures in place to make sure they are
the exact opposite the antithesis of the
experience they had have you found
yourself reacting when you know you
became a dad to yourself yeah I mean
listen I I obviously I I did the same
thing my dad did so I carried on the
circle but with the intention of
breaking the cycle I mean that's the
point I'm gonna listen our intentions
are one thing what actually happens is
is something else and again because I
think I was on a fault line I think
anything I'd chosen to do in my 20s it
would have collapsed you know
um but you know I have a relationship
with my kids that I didn't have with my
father and there I love them and they're
hilarious and they're brilliant and I
love what they do for a living and
that's all wonderful
um yeah you can know you can
you can be held prisoner by trying to
fix the sins of your childhood it's the
truth because here's the truth you know
you're never going to fix them right
they're not you're not going to fix them
you know you you need to build something
for yourself and I think by sort of
thinking no I want a family because I
wasn't able to fix mine
you know so I'm gonna make sure that
this next Generation I fix it in the
next generation and of course it's
doomed to failure you know you're not
gonna you're not gonna create the thing
you wanted to create I think
um so yeah you just have to uh you just
have to you know whatever happened to
you and whatever
you're trying to prove
you saw you sort of have to just you
have to kind of do something for
yourself not not to react against other
people I think
not in a search for justice or yeah but
of course you search for justice and I
might you know but I was of course I
searched for justice and and yeah and I
was such I was certainly to fix things
and I you know I was not able to do
either and neither would I ever be able
to but but in order to try and do it
yeah I you know I I made my own mistakes
you're getting married this year yeah
December December yeah it's exciting in
it for me
no it was nice it was nice to read read
that you're getting married this year
um I've been thinking a lot lately
talking to all my best friends about
this idea of like one partner for life
and I'm going back and forth I'll be
honest with you because I'm here to be
honest I wasn't you know I got
girlfriend she's upstairs but um I was
an um I was on don't tell her this I was
on she might listen you know she
probably will but she
um I'd say the same thing honestly she
can listen to you all day
I don't I think there's so many podcasts
I don't know if she actually yeah
listens to them so exactly because we
record for sale I was on Google this
weekend looking at
chimpanzees mating patterns because I'm
trying to figure out I'm trying to come
to my own this is great listen I hope
she looks Google history is again wow
chimpanzee mating please this guy loves
me I'm trying to figure out if because
they've got like 99 the same DNA as us
yeah
they stick around with the same partner
forever or if they mate within groups
yeah what's your take on this I know
this is such an obscure question to ask
what's your take on whether we're meant
to be with one person for the rest of
our lives uh listen I'm sure some people
are not meant to be with one person but
it's very very hard to do that and not
hurt people and so if you decide if you
genuinely decide
I am not made for that right enough of
this human beings aren't monogamous
right forget that because lots of us are
right so forget it right if you're not
made for it if you don't want to be
monogamous right take responsibility for
that and taking responsibility for that
means not hurting other people and it
means not being in a relationship with
someone who thinks that that is
uh a prospect or a possibility uh and an
awful lot of people take that get out
thing of I just don't think is it
natural I don't think it's natural and
if you think it fine right don't impose
it on everyone else don't impose it on
the women you're with don't compose it
on Partners you know let them be who
they want to be because it really suits
a lot of people very very well I'm in
this relationship now that I pray with
all my heart lasts forever I'm
absolutely certain it will because we're
made for each other completely made for
each other uh and lots of other people
at home will tell you that as well and
lots of people say they're in the wrong
relationship but don't universalize it
don't say oh listen everyone should just
chill out you know like we should we all
have multiple partners it's just it's
the Natural Way listen I've been
Googling chimpanzees listen this cool uh
you know that's all fine but it's you
right it's your responsibility and if
you're not ready to do it okay you've
got to stop wasting people's time uh and
perhaps when you are ready to do it
you'll be like okay this is I mean my
heart was so was so ready and open when
I met Ingrid my partner and Hurst was as
well and you know we both had our
Misadventures that's the truth you know
we really have uh and but we absolutely
were both ready and you know perhaps
you're not ready to be monogamous at
certain ages you know perhaps you're not
but you have got to stop putting it on
other people and stop putting on
chimpanzees and just say what am I what
am I prepared to do and perhaps there's
compromise you know perhaps there is
sacrifice perhaps you perhaps that's
something that you know you'll measure
against other things in the in the you
know and and you'll feel that you don't
want to sacrifice and don't want to
compromise but don't for a single second
say as human nature it's not as you
making a definitive decision and a
definitive time in your life you know
it's it's that's such good advice and I
think I needed to hear that but part of
it is because and I've said this in the
last two episodes or so as it's been
friend of mine for me is seeing of my
close six best friends total failure and
relationships over and over again and me
me being earlier in in that and going
why why 50 of these things breaking if
I've gone to a shop and bought a TV and
the guy said oh by the way there's a 50
chance that's not gonna last yeah
probably wouldn't have bought the TV
yeah but at the same time you spend
years coming out with creative ideas and
you know 50 of them will fail but you do
them anyway
you know it's not a TV you know it's a
it's a life and actually 50 that's not
the worst bet in the world obviously for
50 chance of lifelong happiness I mean
you'd take that bit wouldn't you but
also you know yeah you know you know by
and large you know so the the odds can
certainly in your favor and it's uh you
know I always the best dating thing
anyone ever said to me that's true for
politicians and all sorts of things they
say literally the first date is when
people tell you who they are and then
everything after that is back pedaling
so on your first date with your partner
you would have told her who you were and
what you want from life and where you
want to be and ever since then you've
been back pedaling or saying oh actually
no actually now I think about it I want
this but you know listen listen to what
someone told you on the first date you
know that's who they are and that's what
they want
what other than the story lines and yeah
um The Narrative and everything that's
in this book what are the very
fundamental level do you hope that this
particular book the third the third
installment is doing for the reader at a
very fundamental yeah level well you
know my job is always entertainment you
know that's my thing and um in this book
honestly it's the very Act of of
starting the next chapter that's that's
that's what that's what I aim for you
know you finish one chapter you think I
have I've got to read the next one I
want people to start a long playing
Journey thinking oh god I've got eight
hours and at the end of it going oh my
God that's great I got to read that
whole book you know I want people at
night to go and just give me one more
chapter I just want to read one more
chapter uh and I want people at the end
just to go do you know what that was a
thumping good read you know that really
really entertained me
um I'm gonna tell my friends about it
that's the thing you notice about I mean
it's so true in your business but in
books as well everything is after the
first little initial flush everything is
Word of Mouth yeah everything you know
and these but every it's like people
telling people telling people telling
people and if you've got the right
product then you know it spreads because
people tell their friends but I wanna
All I Wanna Do Is entertain people you
know I'm not I'm not going to be you
know Shakespeare you know I want to give
people a great read that entertains them
that makes them laugh that makes them
cry I want underground work out who the
murderer is uh you know that's what I
want their light their lives to be
minuscularly improved by having read the
book
Richard as you know we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest asks a question for the next guest
right and I only get to see it when we
open the book so here we go
what was the most valuable lesson you've
learned in the last year
and why oh who's that question from
can't tell you oh it is part of the
mystery oh that's right what's the most
valuable lesson I learned in the last
year
gosh that's a good question
um I think that
uh I'm talking about my my kids my my
son was working at wagamama and hated it
hated it it wasn't well treated is my
view uh really didn't enjoy it but he's
a grafter
uh and he's now working at a at a
computer games Museum which is like so
far up history it's amazing uh and I
think
the lesson that I've learned is I should
have said to him two months before he
quit you should just quit this is not do
you know what this is not making you
happy they're not looking after you this
is not you you know and I know working
hard is important but you have got to
quit and go and do something else it's
the truth and I think if you're not
being looked after and you're not
enjoying yourself and you don't see this
is a path to riches you're allowed to
just say
I need to find a workplace where I'm
respected which is what he's done now
Richard thank you thank you for your
time and thank you for
um you know you've done so many amazing
things in your career especially on you
know TV for the first sort of 20 20 30
years of your career but
um writing a book that has touched so
many people in such profound way that is
in every corner of the world that you
wrote yourself
as you've said it takes Word of Mouth to
make a book reach these Heights and that
in and of itself is a testament of how
amazing profound resonant these books
are on so many levels so it's an
inspiration to me you know I was I got
so because I'm writing a book at the
moment with penguin understanding
especially the the create the creative
Journey how you write where you write
the discipline that it's also
excruciatingly painful to you and you
describe it as a marathon has inspired
me so much and there's something really
really special I think in throughout
this book but also just the way that you
create in trusting yourself yeah and
really in building anything it's like
what you said earlier about make
something that you would love yeah
sometimes in my life I've not done that
and it's never gonna ever works right
and that's really sort of made me
reorientate myself towards focusing on
that that true alignment in my
creativity in what I'm building in my
work so thank you for that
um I I think people are gonna absolutely
love this book well I know that for a
fact to be honest um and I hope to be
back here with you someday and have
continue this conversation thank you
Stephen my pleasure
[Music]
foreign
[Music]